okay here we
go be just for this episode if you want
to use that it be a lot to set
up not tell them boy let ra move in with
them you think we should raise it up a
little you think I'm see ask chrisa I
texted
game SI at
the you got a charger
H you got a charger h uh what iPhone
yeah yeah can you send me that can you
can you
one I got it I got it here [__] oh
no I try the move
this
okay all right
hey what's wrong Jolly robbing you right
now he just trying to get you
distracted just say you
yeah I can do thousand for
sure especially by
April right now
oh are we live right now is people
watching on YouTube how many people
watching [__] 30 what's up [__]
[__] we out Shide man what's good
everybody how long ago have they been
did you start go live and I tell about
three minutes oh
damn you got to jump that legit yeah
right yeah it's say if they don't see me
I don't really damn this NG J move a
hole oh you don't smoke H yes oh you do
okay you got as no D I forgot that you
scoot down one oh okay my bad you take
his my
bad
[Music]
trip I'm I mean if you just want to lean
forward or something excuse me all right
also cam you know that shower curtain
right there if you want to pull that
yeah get that with sque job what
you hey that's what he do you got
lighter hunts or Jolly all right cool it
went
out hey thanks you're a good host maning
host it's pretty great thank you it's
free this my bath but it's
healthy one bath that's what saying if
if it is this oh right
here oh yeah can you press the cord
thank you
man invaluable right there yeah I know
we talk that's she was she mat If he if
he could do one thing different he would
get it the street over CU he said you
hear every day all night like n try to
go to sleep you you hear the street you
hear the crackheads all that [__] I want
to hear the crackhead yeah yeah make you
you ain't going too far from home that's
that's a good sleep that's a good sleep
sound for you all the
content somebody go got
stabed can't go too far from the hood
police get off his neck yeah
yeah most people count sheep [__] just
count bullets to go to sleep like I'm
excited bro they're counting every
minute George Floyd was under the knee
oh God oh God
damn yeah yeah especially if nobody we
all be hanging out together n we will
beang
out probably some
chicken yeah we could be working at a
restaurant yeah yeah we could yeah work
at a c restaurant I work my f said D we
probably could work together every
Chinese restaurant I know got a black
Delivery drop probably like Ben H I can
see you with that hat
onck man you shrimp in your
mind shrimps in your mind on
volcano a ligh it's cuz the you do
probably you you got that you got a
lighter brother hey what kind of room
this was before this I don't know like a
reading room yeah got this B got this B
full of got L yeah it's Windows all the
way window you can't really put a bed in
here I you can put a twin this [__]
baby a sun room hell no podcast Ain no
godam I like it though it's nice it got
good saying feel to it like the
beginning of
something
got it that's how you know them boy B
look at they cars know them boy bers too
they be a perch titties too the big old
N Titties those are the best
titties
yeah night
tit oh for sure what's the name what's
the name of the show huh i' give it the
show is called the Asian Express really
you swear to
God um Hans Kim live with G viol
everybody that [__] saying game
violence that saying say you you so
old been live for a minute you ain't
gonna say hey guys hey welcome to the
show I actually did a little thing
before why you put my name last cuz I
don't nobody know me you everybody know
who you is man outside sh made out the
bottom I mean he corz isn't
here I don't know if he like it when you
do racist [__] he's coming he was coming
good yeah he's supposed to legs yeah you
know he got a long walk you know what
I'm saying he walking hell
no people walk everywhere that B that
back gonna be hurting like a
[__] it's like a
uh it's like a
[__] when uh people that don't have a
leg Yeah they walk around with
shorts I pass that
[__]
me seen that
before
yeah looks very weird you be taking it
back you you you don't know what to say
you got on pajamas pajamas them pajamas
them nice pajamas they're just just a
normal dress shirt nah man them nice
pajam how you know you get money your
pajamas look like dress shirts [__]
that's a pajama shirt right that's
pretty funny yeah I that's a pajama
shirt pajama
pattern you going to go to sleep [__]
yeah that's not what kind of shirt is
that that's a pajama shirt it's a
lumberjack it's a lumberjack sht that
hard now that b nice but look you
pattern I like it bro small what you so
what you like to spend your money I'm
now finally getting money in life you
know I like to spend money on H what
cologne oh the nose the sense yeah I
like I like cologne ulating yeah your
face
penis you think the nose is the face
penis yeah I ain't going hold it when
you say like that y Ain got big ass
face you got a burger on you boy that's
a f that you like I had a pelican on
your face oh my god well you got a huge
face
penis so is that like a thing like
people like [__] people with their noses
you never did that that's what [__] a
b from the back and put put your nose in
her booty
no not you get a bit off what yeah you
make
[__] you really get one in there you put
you put uh put your nose in there that
gonna come by 13 times what you ask on
the man table and [__] man bro you a
[__] failure to society it happens
[__] with I'm sorry that the hood
rules I don't follow listen man Hans
done got three black people up here he
gave us drugs he said and then he said
all right hold on let me turn the camera
on I like it up here man that's F yeah
you guys are welcome
even though I'm not here just to come by
all he said that so we going to do that
[__] I'm going do that
[__] playing the game thank
you's
coming I did say that as soon as he
posted Comedy Zone I commented that I
said [__] who you taking to
Jacksonville you hyenas when when you
had hyenas yeah how was that that was
fun hell yeah came out yeah H's good
yeah I did the Red Room all excited I
thought it was fun yeah yeah um yeah I
mean it's crazy that people come
out that's like who are you people but
it's like all of small it's like a large
family it's like everyone the world has
become like y I guess that's someone
else's quote they just want but they
just want to it's cool that people I had
this weird thing when I was at buffo
where was like when people came to see a
[__] yeah I was like I was like in a
weird space cuz I was like I I I don't
think I think it's too early you know
what I'm saying people come to see me
and [__] like that so it felt very weird
yeah and then when I got the feeling I
kind of got to hold like my emotions and
[__] and just did what I supposed to
do I mean that's what we do we kill it
where we go on stage every night yeah at
a certain point it's muscle memory yeah
though yeah that yeah yeah that's all it
is are you going to choose to kill
tonight and be happy or you going to
choose to be sad
and cuz I mean when you think about it
bro killing is easy when you when you
put all the work can you feel what I'm
saying everything else just kind like
especially when the crowd good oh yeah
like fighting a crowd is fun that's it
could be fun fight Crow I love the fight
Crow I miss fighting Crow sometimes yeah
you never do that anymore you miss was
kind of
suck com they coming to be happy but I
miss I miss like making like a [__] see
me and be like what do he have and I be
like all right [__] yeah then BR life
yeah it a bit of like a relaxing of like
okay I know you don't give a [__] about
you know I don't have to say hello
correctly I yeah I don't gotta like if I
lose if I if I lose today here nobody
remember that [__] anyway not like if
you lose now you know I'm saying I like
oh G remember
like oh I downside yeah that's why I
always go to like some [__] Open Mic at
least once a week I don't tell nobody it
be about three people in there and I
bomb hard as [__] it's good for you and
I do that for me know I mean so work
yeah the standup comedy Buzz that you
get is so unnatural and so positive it's
like there's no way this is healthy to
just experence this oh just all
positivity people are so happy to see
you kind unreal I know I'm full of [__]
yeah it's a it's it's a de SW but it's
dope D it's emotionally crazy thing to
put yourself through especially if
you're autistic yeah I like extra extra
stimulation from that from being a
little [__] and then and then
getting that Rush well you got the tism
you think I got the tism L yeah I don't
really connect with people in the way
that everyone else does I'm sort of more
detached and more bemused and yeah
analytical yeah yeah no I feel
you I mean that may but that's good for
you though you yeah I mean to get Social
approval when you're also
like and Psychopathic what what is
psychopathic is crazy what what is
what's what's what is like artistic
though it's just sort of like not fusing
on emotions as much or like
relationships just being like focusing
on your immediate you know Pleasures
what you need to do right now bro lady
called me emotionally [__] one time
like a real therapist CU she thought I
stole [__] from my job and they had to
come like bring in talk to me and [__]
and then she was asking me all these
questions she was like I come to clue
that you might be emotionally
[__] that just mean CU you don't
know what's going on she was like I
don't have like my emotions Wen like
right cuz she told me something about
somebody how would you feel the so and
so Di and I just like [__] they
did
crazy thinking East Tour yeah if I don't
know somebody like that I ain't you know
what I'm saying but how how are you
going to that's why they uh put Amanda
noox it Italy they were like Amanda noox
killed this girl cuz she was acting
weird after the murder but who is to say
what's a normal way to act after murder
yeah like everyone deals with a
different
like some people just be like hey you
did you know what I'm saying like some
people say that's not human but it's
like I ain't going to cry at it you know
like I freak out like hey I got deal
what happened there is a certain whale
that people get when they hear their
loved one that's died when they're not
expecting it like a young person like in
a hospital I saw this video of this cop
that beat the [__] out of this guy and
he ended up dying and they got a video
of the mom in the hospital when they
told her yeah she like because it's like
a part of their souls T like all the sad
screen right yeah bro those those videos
be sad as [__] bro that's like with
dolphins and [__] he said that
Dolphins SE ever seen black fish and
black fish they they separated like a
mama had like my baby dolphin had like a
little whatever the [__] little baby
dolphin called yeah they had one of them
a calf yeah a calf do had a and they
separated the Orca from Mom baby so it
was just sting out like just like
looking it was like it was like it was
making all the noise and [__] like
looking for in t oh Sonic sounds and
[__] that just blasting it on the air
drum and they just sold that
[__] we [__] up that [__]
pretty I mean but that's that's like
people level on like what's the ecos
system or what's good or like some
people like hey we fight these [__]
dogs you know what I'm saying that's
what they do other people fight like
[__] fights and what's the
[__]
that would be
hard on that
[__] I got my money on the white one
with the black
stri them [__] could bite like
a [__] too man you see that [__]
one crazy as they
got you ever SE [__] killer whal but
y'all ever you y'all ever seen black
fish I a never seen whole movie I seen a
little piece it's by seaw right yeah man
one point jumped in the tank he was on
drugs he jumped in the tank trying to
swim with that [__] and it bit
his dick off damn J dick
J B his dick off that's
intentional [__] was smart left him
there bro he he got out so he just
walked around
dickas from what you mean yeah they get
that meat man had that surgery at the
time what he
just
technology wasn't that Advance when this
happened that [__] could have been
saved
today he could just became a woman you
got to act fast too if you if you so
happen to lose your dick what you you
you gotta just be turned into a [__]
yeah n it's a sh I ain't G
Talk and gonna get canc he
over no I mean you know like
noway that's what they happened like you
know they probably would still had them
nuts he could have been the full one nut
nuts offo yeah you got to get them nuts
off you I wonder if I wonder if the or
did take his nuts off that been crazy a
full surgery so would you not like if
that happened to you what are you going
to do with it like I'm getting strap on
[__] I'm going to work oh so you're not
going to turn [__] you too good for
that hell no n I'm F to get the dick I
always
wanted like dudes then I ain't
start I just to get a Les I'm just gonna
get a dick always
ass get the [__] out of here I'm the
only ass ass [__] dickas ass they call
they call your
dickas get out here dickas dickas
[__] dickas
cage di cage oh my God out here dickas
cage you crazy you know they do have
like like uh pornstar people they will
take a celebrity's name and make a pun
out of it for their porn star career
that could happen to one now ask you a
question so when you get the coochie are
you dudes then you like dudes
what if you happen I'm just saying if
you still happen to lose your dick you
you know getting a strap you're not
gonna feel nothing well I'm I ain't
gonna just go get a Coter
[__] down there that's like when
you when them old [__] you keep it in
a jar [__] on your table and that sh be
like this sh but be bald as [__] at the
top that's the same thing you ain't got
no dick but you got them bald every time
[__] with with a D I'm going smack my
nut so I
something smack my
nuts gotta keep them nuts gotta keep
your
nuts I guess I'm wrong I don't know want
a
coochie that's I don't just walk that
boy want a coochie man you don't want to
be a legan or you or you going start
dating if if you I'm at any moment if
you lose your dick that's all I was
saying cuz the story was crazy what
would you do what what would you do you
lose your dick I mean well now that
we've have this research and the
conversation you I'm going just get a
strap off you know appar that's
[Music]
what my
kneecap yeah there a couple steps get my
bed
I'm hit you while I'm on
this be fishing with that [__]
hand me some of that juice slide it down
that
strap got sliding juice down that strap
I want I want me a good 24 Ines man I'm
going to get me one that's crazy yo yeah
I'm F I'm going to impale me a bit Jesus
Christ you can [__] up from a different
room yeah yeah that's the game plan yeah
yeah somebody take my away watching
[__] watching the rest of the
game I'm here watching
Lifetime you got to be able to [__]
people otherwise you walk through the
world differently if you're walking
around with a vagina you're just trying
to get it filled okay about estrogen and
[__] what about this what if what if you
like get paralyzed from the way down
your di net work again what you doing
then that's when you just use your
notes I thought he would say something
real
gay
you got to get a CO so either he gonna
become a lesbi I was presenting another
option for the conversation come on baby
that [__] is crazy a maniac I think that
you uh you know your mouth is like a
sexual Oregon yeah you could feel maybe
you could just get really good at making
out with [__] and eating their boxes
out yeah you can always keep going
basically just turn into a
month be I ain't got nothing down here
for you but I can eat this [__] I'mma
eat this [__] by two days my fing crazy
I be living [__] with my finger like
this I bet you them [__] them [__]
put my finger down here and just [__]
[__] with my finger yeah ah do that
you can yeah yeah your finger do work
now imagine them [__] who in
wheelchairs they get them hoes home they
eating that thing that dick act like
it's getting hard and he just be like a
like he feel like it's a little life in
yeah just looking at like this a
happen come
on it's been 17 years over inch nowhere
damn what do you think going to happen
today well that's what chimps do chimps
go for your hands and your dick because
they know it's important like mean when
they attack yeah chips chimps
chimpanzees chimpanzees like monkeys I
seen one video it was a monkey that b
did like
this that b threw some [__] so
fast [__] throwing [__] at
Orlando the night skinn [__]
that
dude talking that's racist you really
showing
yourself the television man come on a
piece of [__] right now bro
cold pce B it [__] [__] for that what
they saying Hans they're saying they
about to start making Hans do push-ups
like in that one video with Justin
Bieber hey them [__] in the
comment as [__] what does that mean uh
Justin Bieber was in the hood one his
car broke down in the hood one time so
so the people it was like a bunch of
black people walking around he was
trying to act cool and they was like
Justin sing that song for us sing that
song he start doing push-ups and singing
for the
people so they wouldn't beat him I'm a
performer I got to perform yeah it it
was that pressure that's funny as hell
oh man a deep cut yeah that [__] say
cam stop Asian hate damn these [__]
[__] send me nah [__] [__] you just
look it up on YouTube a man hey I don't
never look at the comments them [__]
cold like them redig these [__] oh
[__] are r as
evil oh that I say why would you do this
I hate those hard RS yeah man
hard there a bunch of angry white dudes
don't have any sex they stay in a
basement too and they have miserable
lives because they don't know who they
are they're all like in their young 20s
and they're all doing things they don't
want to do with their life and they're
like I'm miserable why should this
person be happy yeah and then they be in
like a basement yeah that's what like
Spider-Man was really created in a
basement
yeah mad bro mad as [__] I don't get it
yeah we can't read the comments I've
been stopped looking at them except this
one those are nice I like people that
just C just be [__] with it that' be
cool as [__] yeah man people
cool the guy down the street cut his
wife's head
off damn what and kept it in the freezer
then tried to throw her body off the
bridge but she was too heavy so he
pushed her through the rail and the body
got stuck there that be a
fat fat [__] that's why you can't date
fat [__] because it's hard to get rid
of their body it was a it was a lady in
it was a lady in Daytona Beach right she
used to go to these open mics oh yeah
she used to take like her they found two
boyfriends in the freezer chopped up in
her fre chopped up but she used to just
come to the mics and hang out it was one
it was one uh comic what's buddy name I
forget but he in this say he I know him
I know him too I know talking about [__]
he just smoke crack and the lady would
tell like hey like you smoke like she
want you want to go back to my house and
smoke some crack like I guess that's
casual I guess I don't know like she's a
black widow she just wants to take
penises and cut smoke one day was that
her thing yeah that was she uh she lured
people back over with crack it's like if
you do crack you deserve to die Dam
that's she like so SM crack I feel you
also prepared you're prepared to die if
you cra no I'm on the same Vibe I'm on
the same Vibe as uh little booy when it
come to crack I'm I'm a I'm Pro crack I
think crack is great Jack nap that's his
name Jack Jack but I think crack is
greata fin kill [__]
kill crack just make you real good at
one
thing F came out Crack probably killed
four people
and where
you overdosed on crack but you you know
saying you bridge the wrong way but like
they didn't ruin their lives like you
ain't seen black people come back from
crack crack harder than like them bit
still smoke crack they [__] fitting
all murders that's how gen Z does it
they're just like give it to me and just
just D yeah [__] be the fun not really
the funnest [__] but it just be like
heroin that [__] scary boy people who be
on heroin what that's somebody that do
herin we know somebody that do herin all
the time like Keith
Ray they all time say his name but he
always he always
around oh you know about I work at the
place he be doing that whoa where he be
walking in the bathroom and [__] all the
time so what's your favorite uh thing
about Austin comedy scene oh the people
yeah yeah I like the people a lot open
People dope and the amount of the amount
of times you can get up you know what I
mean like in a week you got you got
great shows I got a show that's pretty
good well I mean the other show was
I I had fun was
dope probably about 60 80 people Tuesday
Wednesday an audience like that in an
Austin what that would never happen
never that's liberals the Liberals ran
good shows yeah do you think do you
think like you should go to other places
that are like uh
like nine fans of us but still full yeah
I
like I ain't did I I a't say Lucas did
one of them in a long time though now he
he do but he but mostly he do him at
vogan now what I'm saying
yeah very beautiful yes and not
intelligent you know Dan P D got a
couple dope shows that's like in Austin
but they like but is so hard they off
they off six street I'm going try to get
uh I'm going try to start doing some
like little small [__] in like Houston
and Dallas and [__] you know what I'm
saying just to try to get away from the
what put a show together over there you
say I just hop on like some locally
produ show [__] yeah yeah just to get
pop in without put my name on is a skill
and I've lost it I don't even know how
to talk I don't even know like liberal
is talking to liberals I don't know what
liberal is like white people that are
like proper and they don't want to like
you know they they live proper lives or
like oh yeah it's it's it's definitely
it's definitely gotten a it's definitely
got I feel like I got more vulgar been
out here more like you know what I'm
saying whatever the [__] CU you can say
whatever the [__] you
want thing but I think whatever muscle
you build it don't matter how you say it
if that's how you g to say it that it's
going to win you know what I'm saying
like but I feel like comedy is and they
say check the mic I don't know they I
don't know who mic or but they say check
somebody mic
yo I think johnley maybe yo yo yo yo no
we
good yeah like like uh I don't know wait
Hans you've been out longer what's your
favorite thing about this you you you
know what to hate and what to
love I love the only been in three
months upper tier Echelon of Comedy that
you know the comedy Mothership
represents yeah F I love that there's a
Avenue a well flowing stream of people
flowing I mean maybe I'm biased because
I only hang around you know kill Tony
people but you can see like you know
what I'm saying you you can see like the
scene like really build like Monsters
you know what I'm saying like it's
really like it's going to make you good
it's attract the monster and it's
building monster we have so much time on
stage type [__] hell yeah you know what
I'm saying like you can like you last
night I did 30 minutes in one
night that's [__] well 32 minutes if
you do that four days a week that's
that's two hours you just spend on stage
I think City Comedy too it's not road
comedy you're doing it in the city with
smart people that are up to date if you
make a noic reference they're G to get
it yeah okay yeah I feel mean white
[__] has been using to get
skinny okay I understand that I get that
[__] too
H even if you don't understand it you
can learn from the context clues the
audience I know you do that joke about
it I know exactly what you talking about
but I know I didn't know what it was you
know but you kind of explain it well so
I like okay cool I thought I thought OIC
me like like a adjective or something
not like yeah OIC to you sir J that [__]
so [__] funny that so
hard all y'all all y'all killed that
[__] in the Florida theater bro I
watched the whole show from the side
stage all three of y' I pissed that was
the first time I got that was the first
time I got to see y'all in a theater so
you ever you ever get like a Zone like a
I was in like a mo I was like okay
everything going really well and it felt
like I was like oh this is going great
then that [__] M stand broke [__]
hand it profession I handled it
professionally but I could tell in my
mind like it was some more you know what
I'm saying like it was like yeah yeah
yeah but I'm glad you ain't get deep in
your head no I stumbled over a couple
things and I just kept moving but yeah
but yeah you kept moving I'm saying I
was trying to telepathic talk to
him spe if if you were at the show you
know cam when cam did a joke pretty much
the mic stand broke uh while he was on
stage uh so uh I I told it wasn't even
that bad though like you know it it it
still went with the only thing was tried
to pick it up he tried to pick it up and
put it back together people think comedy
is
like you're like Tom arold yeah I'm
saying it's a flow so when the flow got
disrupted you know I'm saying when the
flow got my brain kind of like spit up
for a second but [__] you ever like
uh I I kind of I kind of uh say like
it's like spinning out when you on the
road raining a lot you start you have no
control yeah car you g to let that [__]
spin for a second and then just keep
when this all you know saying that's
kind of what it felt like hey that [__]
was like the way it went cuz I'm like
damn how they going to make this [__]
here happen and he just you know
you what he do you know that [__] was
dope bro came out sh was so dope my
favorite part I don't know I don't know
if y like as much as I do I like I like
that that little moment that we had to
say something to each other yeah before
like before we start talking that's my
favorite part of the theater oh yeah
small little moment like hey man that's
that
[__]
y' I don't know come out but but when
y'all threw the money to each other I
thought and uh in FL that that [__] was
pretty cool I know and I forgot
yeah I was like I thought that was cool
as
[__] shout out to Ton Tony Tony I love
Tony now that's my [__] bro I was so
happy bro when Tony came out that [__]
say he told me he so y here breaking
[__]
huh
break cool though bro that [__] is
different bro
3,000 you don't like that you don't like
that part no uh Tony says the funniest
things like yesterday when I was getting
on stage he gave me this giant intro his
intros are the best oh the best in
comedy and then he was like welcome to
the big
leagues had to follow that intro yeah
yeah yeah I mean yeah it's it make you
it make you work hard to do yeah it make
you it make you but I think I live up to
it [__] you know I'm saying your head
though like when you trick your own
brain like what you saying to the people
tricking your that [__] it's like it's
like it has to happen this become your
reality because you made it your reality
you know what I'm saying like the
repetition of just comedy itself when
you just get to a point where you like I
know this [__] joke [__] I'm G to
bang this [__] I'mma do this
[__] in front of the preacher and they
gonna laugh you know what I mean I'mma
tell that bit to God yeah you feel me he
like
that I don't like it too
much but I like
son you a smart
[__]
[Music]
that I like that I like where you were
going with it I'm glad I gave you my
last sign for this you know but
it's I'm glad you give it somebody
something [__] for real I mean 3,000
people was crazy man especially because
they're the best crowds I think in the
world yeah kill Tony fans and Tony Hench
Cliff fans they're joke they really love
it I like I like and they understand the
dance yes you can say anything I like
when people come to me they be like oh
yeah the joke you did on K T like you
know I got too much [__] everything I
do on K I'm I'm throwing out that and
I'm still working on it like you know
I'm saying as we speak but you make it
better like the next thing I'm saying
that bit so people come see me and [__]
these people have no idea how Comedy
Works they just watch kill Tony like
kill Tony is great but that's not comedy
that's like but when they seeing the
live
like the live shows the Tony hinchliff
tour that's the beauty behind it because
now they really fall love with you know
what I'm saying by getting that 15
minutes from you that 15 from him that
hour from Tony now they like damn we got
to get some more of this [__] I see why
they I see what we legit working our
asses off you feel what I'm saying see
minutes every week [__] that [__] like
you feel me hell yeah that's a different
type of pressure [__] [__] pretty the
way y'all do write a write new jokes
every week like a I mean it's homework
bro like you feel me you got to go do
your homework but that's that's cool as
[__] that [__] make you like it's good I
mean before I did Kill Tony I was like
oh yeah I could do that you know that'd
be fun to display what I've been working
on people grow with me hell yeah and
people get a [__] I like I like I like
when I have like I like when I have like
a mediocre set and I turn a one a joke
that's mediocre into some [__] that's
funny like sometime sometimes like I I
think of some [__] like before you know
what I'm saying it's like okay I try
this [__] don't really got nothing going
on
you feel what I'm saying but then I like
when I really get like punches and beats
to it people come see it like oh it's so
different from what I thought that [__]
was terrible like yeah I wrote that when
I was taking a [__] and I was like you
feel now it's becoming something you
know what saying it's develop and ideas
take time and the way you trick an
audience is like and you need to like
figure it out but it's almost like a
recipe yeah if you do it mathematically
but some people don't like to think
about it like that but if you like say
the right things in the right tone of
voice they can't help but laugh like
there is a right answer to solve this
puzzle any any
crowd what it do hell yeah I mean be C
that [__] that [__] I don't know
which one the clear water or the
Jacksonville both of them shits was
[__] [__] to me man it was crazy
clear water I think I like I like Clear
Water theater better than Scientology
yeah it all nice but the way it went up
like that yeah that little what's name
right there that [__] that [__] play
like so well into like comedy it was
that I I wish you would have did a
what's name with us oh both y'all [__]
would have did what San die Phoenix
Phoenix oh the in the rounds [__] that
was my favorite that was my favorite set
of my life that [__] L took com right
now yeah did they record it Christie
they I think they got somewh they got to
get that tape bro that [__] do they were
you playing it like you had to play I
been following up like like this show
for you I'm not worried I I move anyway
like I walk around anyway so I wasn't
even really like walking around like I
was kind of like sporadically just I
what I was trying to do I I think I was
like I tell I making like a star so I
like go up to this side come back to the
middle tell some [__] go back up to this
side go back to the
mid instead of like walking like a
circle know what I'm saying so I was
trying to play it like but the best
thing about it is [__] it's four front
rows yeah so you tell a joke this way
you getting from your ass it's like what
the you see my face you know you getting
punched in the back of the head by laugh
you can [__] punch you the side of
everybody laugh so it's like this [__]
just like you know what I'm saying it
was just from all angles you could hear
it like it would like if you bombing
around you just ain't putting no work in
you feel what I'm saying like it's it'
be crazy cuz all you got to do is play
to the audience man not even play but
it's like I mean like looking at them
they make it so easy like it's so it's
like like a mediocre set there is like I
know like a like a medoc set in any
other room is like a murderer you know
what I'm saying because it's so like
even if you don't if you not feeling
yourself yet or something like that and
you know what I'm saying you don't feel
like they dancing with you it's going to
S they dancing with you because how how
many people is like you know I'm saying
yeah that [__] that [__] was my favorite
venue so like so far for sure stage move
in the
circle you can get the move but I think
they do that [__] for like music and
[__] that' be kind of crazy what has
anybody ever I've never seen nobody do
stand up from a moving stage that'd be
hard though I bet you somebody gonna do
it I went down somebody gonna do it I
can see that Kevin Hart like break
record D somebody said why the [__] cam
on his phone [__] I'm reading the chat
I want to see what y'all [__] talking
about see collaborate with y'all [__]
you guys can't be discriminatory this is
how they're neurod Divergent yeah
they're in three places at once that bch
say check your wallet Hans I got it
check my wallet I got
it
yeah black people are the best magicians
they make a wallet disappear man sto
your whole
car it's my piece he disassembled it and
then put it together David bla can make
the little Indian [__] got it see we
working as a team what we
just got that [__] K squ got the C he
gone man he got your van is that crazy
that some Indian people can look like
black people yeah that [__] crazy I met
a Sher lincol [__] what's SRI
lanig L what did you call
Lan l l Usher Lincoln is what it sound
like you talking about Usher what's my
[__] my [__] name Abraham lincol I
forgot my dog name but he sure he sure
Lincoln [__] and he look when I met him
I like you black he at first he was like
yeah I like you really black he like nah
I'm not black I like Dell bro old sh
Lanka old sh Lan he got it's like when I
see someone from Kazakhstan that's like
oh you look kind of Asian but there's a
little bit of white in you yeah you do
you think you can tell different Asians
apart easily yes yeah okay all right
what kind of Asian is Jolly I would say
you're from
Nigeria that makes sense never West
Africa I don't know West Africa that
much I probably would be from I probably
be from like somewhere beautiful like uh
Egypt or something I'm from Hawaii so
you know what what what what kind you
think he is like uh look at
thatan look at that Burger on
his he probably Middle Eastern you got
to know it's like a middle
eastern you might be mied with Jewish
hey well rub me my money yeah I need all
mine I got I got Jewish friends now H I
got like a couple of Jewish friends I
love Jewish people love them you think
black people are good at stealing
[Laughter]
stealing from the Great White Beast this
whole time hey hey Jewish people I
didn't say this yeah I love Jewish
people I love nothing about respect I
respect your hustle I love every person
in my corner
[__] steal from the whites I don't
steal no
more you know 2018 yeah that [__] 20 20
2020 I thought I got arrested for
stealing you feeling coming on me yeah
are you a robber you got your you look
like you're in the black Home
Alone yeah you do yeah you do why you
got your name on yourt I be good at
setting traps what why you got your name
on your you sell them shirts right there
uh yeah like I like hoodies and stuff
yeah and podcast on the back you should
put a good ass joke on that [__] yeah
well honestly that was the thing I just
started making it I don't even I don't
know which joke of mind that I would put
up there yet you know I don't want to
just throw anyone on there I'm still I'm
still working on [__] that I
want man [__] that's that that is the
idea when you get a good ass joke you
get a good ass tag people run that for
the rest of their life you can do that
what that'd be the kick of that merch y
got start doing I remember I was telling
jar the funny [__] I was telling jar I
said I was like bro I I Su my soul I
like taking pictures of people because I
want to set them something that I don't
think is like buy it and then J like you
know what that makes sense he T back
like to he said wait a minute [__] you
used to rob people what the [__] now you
care about people think about you [__] by
merchandise you better get these
$25 get your ass up body I sell merch
you feel me yeah say I got now you don't
like people who steal huh you're like
the opposite you became everything you
hated no well I mean I I just say a mer
I don't steal so uh what was your
mentality when you were stealing were
you like I deserve this or these people
won't feel bad about it or what you oh
no that's all a mil man all that we
never stole anything I soole from Target
and I got arrested me and great like
real arrested yeah yeah like why got
they were looking at me through the
video I was just going through Target
just putting things in my what you
steing did you take something good pots
and pans
and can't go to jail over pots and pans
huh
wait you was in a where you was Atlanta
damn oh damn you tried to go to the
black T starty jail Dam how oh you was
in that b with
little boy yeah probably like three
hours so you you really took pots and
pans and tried to steal yeah why why
didn't you just get better stuff why why
would I get better stuff I wanted that I
needed that I was like let me get the
best pots and pans that they have here
um but yeah I mean uh was it this was
recent this was in college when I was
like a junior or something and then I
got they had this pre-trial diversion
for misdemeanor
first time offenders in the house I was
in the fton county J what colle you went
to in Georgia Tech Georgia te oh yeah
yeah I went there for a semester no
way now I went to Valencia and I dropped
that good I went to Florida A&M and um
college is so [__] yeah I mean but
you know what black you meet the People
You Meet are great the people you meet
but you don't even have to be enrolled
there you can just hang out I I didn't
get into Florida state but I got in
every comedy troop over there so that's
how I started doing comedy I ain't hold
you [__] I would just I will only go to
college for like the homecomings you
know what I'm saying like when I when I
graduated I was at every homecoming you
could think of me and my dog outside I
went I went to you homecoming I ain't
even go to fam I want to fam you
homecoming bought a fam you shirt had
Gold T and just sat outside the fresh
door I po here freshman myself I sat
outside the fresh door with just
blissing hey it was day it was crazy I
crack me I I crack me a couple to
college girls are the hottest and it
just proves that age is beauty hey I
can't lie when I was in college uh it
was a place called gumes Pizza remember
that [__] at yeah 79 yeah them [__]
used to [__] for gumes that's disgust
[__] was [__] for disgusting
P that's that's Austin that's like
[__] [__] for
Ros that's lower than rep that was some
real slit hey [__] was brok and hungry
back then
polos is crazy if you SE your daughter
to call she got a [__] for some pizza
you feel
that's she wanted to get some [__] up a
little bit she you know you you hit her
hey what you doing you know you live out
there in phase three the on campus
Apartments [__] nobody order a little
[Music]
gumbies get little s you got some of
that regim Miller weed with the seeds in
that
bill [__] I keep them seeds in there
[__] that [__] put it all together well
let me see how the seeds smoke [__] no
no I take the seeds out [__] give you a
headache they probably did so yeah you
know back you old what you went to colge
1976 no I graduated to high school 99 so
I started school 2000 99 2000 yeah that
[__] good damn boy you had the good at
music when you was in college boy good
good cash
money was high school cash was high
school that's song came out of how when
you cash money taking over yeah that
b yeah that bch that [__] man the ho
just get loose to that
[__] yeah it's it's a it's a it's iic
it's a forever hit but when that [__]
like when you hear that bit we done took
over H
podcast like what are these blocks toown
yeah um you remember Usher Yeah yeah
yeah that's a good oh yeah that's what I
was grinding to in high school that's
what that's what ho was [__] to in
your Usher Yeah Usher soldja boy all
right soja boy got the ho he had
bro anybody doing the best Crank that
you get the you getting some hoes at the
party bro if you was killing that bit
girls used to like dancing girls used to
like dancing if you was the best dancer
girls girls don't like dancing anymore
sad that abortion is illegal
dang just all Moody all the time I know
I know in a Florida it's still legal in
Florida right the dance dance abortion
oh I don't know sh I
know
H [__] people David
J you can buy piss at Magic mall right
yeah hell yeah and that J Mar you can
buy that [__] all around the city I
have to take a drug test when I when I
was still smoking and my uncle like you
you still smoking we can get you some
piss what we can buy you some piss you
just got to warm that [__] up what that
bit be Faker than a [__] but if
you it appear now you got to get one of
them fake dicks yeah when you doing it
for probation I used I used to work a
smoke shop in Jacksonville and I would I
had to open every morning I would sell
those people would come in like from
8:00 like as soon as I would open the
door just for the the the quick the
Quick Fix p with the the ones with the
penises on it the deal all that [__]
size dicks they came bro I had to sell
it was it was a white dude but we a have
no more white dicks left so that
[__] that [__] had that [__] had to
get the blackest
[__] little off color I got sun on but
when they need to pass that test
boy damn you winning that b with a black
dick that [__] crazy that was like my my
second penis cuzz you basically got a
piss in front of somebody you know what
I mean it's not your dick Timothy shis a
dick I promise you this my dick what if
you got old gay officer play over
there out of hand man it's man over here
trying to look at my goddamn package
that's crazy bro yeah that was like my
second year doing comedy I would just
sit and play specials the whole I I
would cut all the I cut the store music
off and just play specials when people
was walking in yeah that [__] was fun I
missed that job they didn't pay me [__]
though I was just selling Vapes and all
these job never do [__] yeah man I I I
don't know I had I remember I wor the
Taco Bell when I was like 16 I remember
them [__] Rob Taco Bell the one on
curtain yeah man the [__] came in
that [__] I was talking on the
phone I had some cinnamon twists I was
bagging up I looked up buty had a gun I
say the [__] manager got the key to
the sav and that [__] can
open that [__] can't open it don't you
let this whole lot of you try to you a
even try to protect it why
you Taco bear [__] [__] I made like
[__] six your first crazy [__] that's
why I make you manager I still work I
work like two I wor I stay working there
you gave up to playing easily Bro [__]
I'mma do you so the
game selfed that's true you can
do my manager my manager like had me
brain brain he told me he would tell me
my time like he was like a man real [__]
like somebody come here and Ste on this
Foot Locker that mean they looked at you
saw you and said this guy's a
[__] are you a [__] I like I'm not a
[__] he's like let me tell you some
real [__] at foot loock we do not Chase
anybody we don't chase nobody they leave
some sh we let them go then walk away
from the camera he said we Chase
everybody we'll run [__] out the store
all type of [__] Bro [__] goddamn get
tackled in that [__] oh what man
one day it was a [__] it was a dude a
homeless [__] walked in put on some
phone pil [__] like 250 put on some
phone pil
he said call the head of Nike he said I
can have these I said what call the
holder Nike he said I can have these he
tried to walk out and so we closed the
gate on his ass and just dragged him
back inside it fell on him like Indiana
Jones oh I mean he was trying to I mean
he seen the gate coming down and then he
tried to he tried to he tried to go
under that bit we just act pull him back
they had to try to R the footage y'all
ain't y'all ain't take budy in the back
and and give him old I ain't going hold
you that's how you don't Rob Foot
Lockers in the hood you go to the white
places not going I ain't going to
hold we were doing that [__] for fun
[__] yeah ain't nothing else to do take
this [__] down you would have take oh I
Dave Jolly obviously doesn't follow the
code of conduct n but see like nobody
had no gun in my face it was just [__]
my AG I like I'm I'mma get it I'mma just
[__] with you yeah t there's a counter
so they feel safe like you can't jump at
them but I was going like [__] like you
got a gun like I make $6 hour crazy even
that feel like one of my my managers
Chas somebody outside to the car I'll
never go outside I get I I wouldn't I
really wouldn't even take your ass past
the store I just be like n
got shot the [__] out your ass what
that's a funny story boy yeah that [__]
funny here you do got to make sure you
can beat up the person you trying to
steal
from all imagine all the fail robberies
you got to be embarrassed
boy there need to be a show that just
taped the [__] who lost when they was
trying to rob somebody open shoe box one
day [__] walked in bro it was some it
was some damn Team Jordans it was a box
of 12 bro I'm counter shoe I sell [__]
shoe I go back on the camera this [__]
took one of the shoes out the b just
walked out with that [__] with
one shoe no with just the box cuz the
whole the whole thing was out on know
what I'm saying they like you just throw
some Team Jordan you a evil [__] bro
Evil Boy Evil [__] white people white
people Team Jordan is something that
black people don't care about them the
bad Jordans yeah so so don't get no Team
Jordans hell no [__] [__] stupid damn
I wanted some of them [__] I mean
they not bad I mean they just I mean it
just I know behind that curtain there's
a toilet
paper hey that [__] say r that [__]
say rck Diaz sitting in the car outside
in the parking lot we'll jump R
Diaz out of he Public Enemy Number One
we'll beat the
D hey man [__] [__] Rick Diaz and look
at the camera said too man [__] that
[__] Rick Diaz Man team Kim team Kim N
I got my jokes already written out I
just have to say them I blocked the [__]
out of R man how did you
feel like are you are you he think but
that [__] pissed me off bro he was mad
so I I didn't I know way to act like
you're an alpha but not even that it
just like bro you got everything
somebody else you know what I'm saying
everybody kind of he's like how do I get
more yeah like bro just be excited let
the [__] golden ticket bro yeah bro you
was in a great position everybody loved
the [__] I was like but I even thought
he was a good guy at first start ex [__]
it ain't no way he gonna beat H Kim you
hear me this the mighty Hans Kim in
Clear Water that [__] got 17 Applause
break that's what I'm saying
Jacksonville Hans out there like with
his hand like this like [__] I'm about
to rip
that [__] don't get straight kill that
this [__] H's a real murderer [__]
murderer so it's like man that [__]
[__] bro that [__] that [__] Rick
Diaz a real bch that [__] was that [__]
was cool at all bro like that [__] it
just wasn't cool you basically got a
regular you already you basically a
regular whenever you come in town bro
you can do you know what I'm saying you
can STI turn don't tell people good for
him he got a little boost but it's all
contingent on what happens but at the
end of the day when he lose now it's all
for nothing yeah and now he's known as a
guy that did some weird [__] yeah
negative energy you don't want those
people coming out to see your thought
but it were like a good dude at first
and they try out tell him like yeah bro
like welcome to the family type [__]
like you know I'm saying [__] gonna
change a little bit for you you know I'm
saying you going be able to do more show
[__] like that but just keep and then he
started doing that weird [__] like what
was the what was the point of that you
know what I'm saying there was no real
point I don't like he was telling me he
was like it's like the circus the circus
J like this is before he left I'm like
what what you mean like he he would say
crazy [__] try to instead me flip out on
his ass tell I told him one time I was
like what to the family said I'm not in
the family yet I what the [__] that even
mean that like some some
Rel know no bounds to make my own family
actually I'm going to be the head of
this family D [__] calm down bro relax
man you going to get B [__] chill you
know he's like 47 yeah he old as [__] no
way I mean I'm I'm 42 but I don't think
I'm old you know what I mean like yeah
you're wise and like
47 you're black but he's white yeah he's
no culture except colonization I say his
skin other than that he I mean he a
decent he a funny guy but that nigga's
an [__] he a dick so feel me I'm
excited to watch it's gonna be great
that's not how Comedy Works you don't
just like challenge people until you get
to the top of Comedy like what you know
you know what's missing in comedy what's
missing in real life good old ass
weapons man what when you can just get a
[__] a good old ass we real [__]
real quick the world was a better place
man when you could just say you know
what hey I don't like what you doing
well I don't like what you doing well
come out here and get in this
grass you just
got Duke a bit CH and then at the end of
the day you ass go home D [__] out me
buddy all right hey have a good day man
you you know hey check kiss your wife
and kids everybody was good you got out
of line again you asked him hey you want
another one then he probably going to
say no if you do him good he GNA be like
I don't want to do that to myself again
changes his attitude
permanently ass whoop man they took ass
womens out of out of real life you know
what he's European too so he's like
super removed from any sort of physical
world he's just purely theoretical like
oh if I go here then this will happen
that would be good for my career yeah he
don't want to throw them hands you think
You' take him down yeah beat [__] out of
he's like 145 lbs yeah you what you
about 180 a't I'm 17 s.6 yeah you a
[__] body slam the [__] out of there
I enjoy wrestling I love wrestling how
long you been wrestling um like two
years hell yeah you do do you do the uh
I stop doing it bra
Jiu-Jitsu I try to use that why you stop
but you still know it hurt my neck oh
and it [__] you up it [__] it's still
[__] me up it's not worth it I'd
rather not know how to fight you know
the boys the boys at the mothership do
that they be trying to get me to do it
but I I want to get in the box and [__]
I get back to shake I'm start ride my
bike every I not want to get a car might
just start riding you get close enough
but you don't ride that bit from where
you at
now that's what that's what Tony do you
you ain't Tony [__] Tony yeah Tony got
full call Tony got do physical [__] Tony
will he got a van a car a bik AE he he
do physical [__] during the day B you
wake up and check your
emails Tony Willis got a man job boy
trying to get a bike in the winter time
[__]
it's bite before I moved out here I mean
I'm not telling you do it nah [__] [__]
that's a long ride that's way farther
than going from from over there to ow
Center to downtown Orlando B that's way
farther yeah that b
that that far of a trck for real once
you start really riding that [__] you
there that like about mile and a half D
yeah you get there about 10 minutes at
the most n my my ride work like
20 to oh yeah but you going all the way
to to to there I'm talking about like
okay yeah if you getting all the way to
Central yeah that [__] going to take a
little time bu like 20 minutes man I a I
ain't getting no bike thank you if I
live downtown I get a bik I just want to
get back and [__] and then it'll be like
you know saying some more motivation get
in shape in other ways man [__] you [__]
just get a
uh get a get a um get a what wrong with
it what get
one rock oh cold
rocks I like cold I like I like cold
rock yeah yeah I'm not [__] about I
like cold rocks or get get one of them
gym memberships I got me a plet fitness
I'm I'm G to get me a gold I'm G to get
me a gold by I wake up at like 4 5
o'clock in the morning man and go to the
gym I go to the gym I go work out at the
one by the crib I walk back to the house
I do all my emails or whatever I got to
do take a bath take me a nap I mean I
always organized I always been organized
you we had to to some real leaks of
bounds [__] yeah I'm just saying man I
I've always been an organized person I
know how to I never been a gym [__]
it's too much it should be hurting the
next day it's just whatever I mean once
you start doing it you go to the gym
don't you yeah yeah that I I have a
little kettle bell I have a 35 pounder
oh yeah that's brace my cor why' you
[__] your hands like that you just
that's how you do it my hands that's
that one he' be working on his uh his
glutes he got doing dips he doing dips
and [__] strength
is you got to learn how to be strong by
learning how to tense certain muscles
I'm gaining weight like a [__]
so I need to get back you feel boy look
that that weight be hard to get off you
once you
get yeah I know but you got to keep keep
on [__] around you going to be like
how Marvin how Marvin was B [__] built
crazy I built like go like a sack of
potatoes sack of [__] potatoes man
you don't want that either that [__]
crazy my boy Marvin was shaped funny as
hell man then he had a heart attack you
know you meant my boy the Puerto Rican
dude that be in mixes sometimes he had a
heart attack he did he alive he good now
he had surgery or something right yeah
then about he had a heart attack and
about two weeks later he came back to
Austin I said this [__] crazy all you
want it everybody coming I hope they all
can State I see a lot of [__] leave
but I mean that you got to be able to
you got to be
funny one thing about Austin comedy that
[__] going to let you know where you at
you know what I'm saying true good
assessment good evaluation what's the
first thing that people come to when
they come to Austin of the creek they
the open mics there Creek and then I
mean cuz the Creek is inviting like
that's a real comedy Hub to where no
matter what level of Comedy I feel like
I feel like I feel like it go like in
levels like it's like a video game so
like the creek like start a club started
the creek yeah you know what I'm saying
get you know saying get your [__] down
in the creek you know what I'm saying
and they probably head over to like
Sunset East Austin East
Austin yeah go to East Austin go to Ros
get in there and then you getting the
sunset yeah you know [__] that [__]
that's a good break now yeah because
then when you really blackb I mean black
rabbit black rabbit is so Aus yeah but
black rabbit is one of the best ones in
City one of the best rooms in the C it's
not even no like it's not even no
question we have a show coming soon the
black rabbit the big black comedy show
oh yeah the it's like the 16th BBC
January 16th J 16th but I be forgetting
I I ain't gonna say like I forget about
it but I guess I be so busy like rosos
is a great Club but I don't I don't like
being
get like David L I love that [__] David
Lucas but hell no I'm going to get back
in shap it's his birthday today too oh
David Lucas his birthday every birthday
celebrate he doesn't have many
left
godamn feeling hey you know he
G birthday H Mexican Trump supporter you
look like you celebrate January 16th
because it's a kingon year oh that's
15th what Mexican Trump
K yeah I see where you trying to
go that didn't answer the question but
what was the question I said when is
your birthday May 31st 1989
1989 yes you know like people are really
paranoid about giving that out because
like why birthday you can use that to
find your uh social security number oh
things you can make like clones of
people
too well uh birday
if you had a clone what what jobs would
you have him do that you don't like to
do that's clones yeah I probably have
him hang out with my girlfriend and I
just do comedy damn you gonna let him
[__] [__] that is you be out there
chilling or you g be like was a clone of
you I be like anytime you want to have
sex I'm gonna cut his dick off I'm gonna
make a swim with orcas so he doesn't
have that boy co get that godam
dle going to come back and ram ram this
why does your smell like
plastic damn he can't feel it but godam
he F to Ram the [__] out that [__] I
don't know I feel like hanging out with
a girlfriend takes a lot of
time and comedy it's like 15 minutes and
it's like over and it's great and it
feels like you're doing something with
your life yeah and then the girlriend
when when I'm writing sometime that [__]
take a while yeah yeah that'd be the
hardest [__] yeah writing alone cuz I
did comedy cuz I want to be around other
people but to write comedy you have to
be alone and face your worst fear of
being alone you know and I don't know
whenever I whenever I try to write I try
to listen back to my sets and then that
those are the days I I be hitting pause
like every 30 seconds I'd be like ah
[__] let me let me like damn I'm so
brilliant and then like when you get a
good premise to or like a old joke that
you used to have and now you know how to
tell it and you bring that [__] back
just like damn not a bit H
what so what are the comments saying uh
not too much no
more somebody said water rocks somebody
said stem cells for your
neck that make you stronger on I saw you
in Vancouver you were great thank you
for taking the picture with him hell
yeah experience I take pictures with
everyone unless I'm in a bad mood like
you be in bad mood sometimes yeah like
once I was arguing with my my girlfriend
on six Street shout
out and so was like I like dude I just
can't right
now you just stop the argument oh no you
you m argument yeah yeah like tap D cool
yeah them [__] be pretty cool yeah
awkward you be with your shorty and then
like just yeah I want to have a
conversation I don't always want to just
like do the customary you be with your
girl and and and then and then a
sometimes a flyer girl will come up and
be like hey let's take a picture that'
be feeling weird with my girl no cuz she
is the beauty of my eye I tried to catch
him up yeah [__] you
AG a real [__] the kind of girl no
I'm just kidding um no I would uh love
to touch different kind of women but I
wouldn't cheat on my girlfriend because
that's like a [__] up thing to
do
oh oh about what y'all ready to do I
ain't saying that I'm just saying you
know we gota go to work yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's get out of here yeah yeah
this is fun okay of the
range it's 500 and